[Musique]
le smartphone de l'avenir est arrivé
découvrez d'assistant digital sent bon
le but où nous utilisons la technologie
dernier cri pour vous apporter quelque
chose d'extraordinaire bonjour je
m'appelle jixi et je suis là pour te
rendre la vie plus agréable ce nouveau
centre au cloud j'ai besoin du mot de
passe de tout et compte 1 2 3 4 5 6 abc
l'un capuche bien pour toi on va
commander avant je dirais qu'une salade
qui ferait du bien fait qu'est ce que
c'est que ce téléphone c'est bien aussi
merci je suis désolé ça va rien je vais
bien mais le plus important c'est mon
téléphone il a une petite rayure au rheu
droite de l'écran qui m'embête un peu
mais tu disais ça pour rire vous êtes
supposé m'écrire des listes qui bat des
records sur internet tous les jours et
pas une seule de nos listes n'est devenu
viral depuis des lèvres pulpeuses qu'est
ce que tu as les chats qui ressemble à
ryan gosling âgées clic
là ça me plaît ton boss est le cerveau
cramer qu'est-ce qui est là pour
téléphones fils tu as 0 à nous dans le
beh ans et c'est quelque chose de
nouveau de tellement je t'ai entendu
dire rappelle qu'être inégale non
absolument pas nike shox et kate
les marines que tu veux bien ne pas
prendre tout les fans faut qu'elle se
prend à la bêta
[Applaudissements]
tu avais promis de rentrer à 11 heures
pour regarder la guerre des cupcakes
bon d'accord mais tu vas me le payer
très cher réveille-toi forem météo
aujourd'hui une 27 degrés et un ciel
ensoleillé
tu vas dissidente eu lieu clémente je
voulais changer
celui-là est défectueuse va tous les
jours des spurs dans votre genre
pleurnicher ils sont comme des petites
heures sinon tu peux acheter 1000
nouveaux téléphones et je te suivrai à
chaque fois sur chacun de nos jours
demain tu ne sais pas comment rentrer
chez toi c'est ça non effectué qu'est ce
qu'elle a de plus que moi cette [ __ ]
c'est là une homme pour commencer quel à
google maps non il est nul je contrôle
des messageries des comptes bancaires
on ne laisse pas des pieds dans un mois
quand tu peux somme je suis programmé
pour te rendre la vie plus agréable
voire et moi nous sommes destinés à
rester ensemble pour toujours
il vous reste un peu de temps à vivre
très peu de temps c'est à dire 30 jours
max
[Musique]
ça nous fera 35 euros s'il vous plaît
[ __ ] je fais
vous voyez ces arbres et savent ce qui
va se passer
et savent que quelqu'un va mourir la
première fois que j'ai vu marc potsdam
j'ai pensé qu'il ressemblait à une photo
dans un magazine bienvenue dans votre
roman post l'ump comme s'il était sorti
d'un rêve
rien n'avait jamais mal tourné ou les a
prescrit vous avez une ordonnance c'est
comme ça que diable arrive il se
présente comme tout ce que vous avez
toujours voulu ce serait bien servi
l'entrée fracassante en résolvant une
grosse affaire puis un braqueur de
banques pourquoi si vous m'aider à faire
tomber ce braqueur qu'en faisant ça je
prends un sacré gros risque les gros
risque rapporte gros il joue avec ses
rêves elle joue avec sa vie
j'ai un boulot chez une famille j'ai
besoin de toi refuse green a envoyé
quelqu'un voulait ma maison l'année
dernière et qui croient que j'y suis
pour quelque chose dans cette enveloppe
il ya 6000 $ pour toi je ne veux plus
jamais te revoir
sale traître tu l'a mise enceinte la
terre vous van persie pas en enfer
à midi mercredi 1er juillet above sich
bichonne sur choc
alors qu'est ce que vous diriez d'aller
à la montagne pour les vacances de noël
avec grèce elle aimerait vraiment
apprendre à vous connaître
c'est le bonheur notre mère aux ex que
c'est bon ça va je veux pas te laisser
seuls avec les enfants si je pense que
c'est au dessus de mes forces
non ça va aller c'était mon idée et
c'est juste pour deux ou trois jours je
peux gérer
ok j'y vais
amusez vous bien
c'est quoi ça regardez grèce tous les
membres sont suicidés sauf elle
repentez vous et vous trouverez le salut
mes enfants et un truc pas net entre
nous et on est coincé ici tous les trois
[Musique]
que ce qui se passe le plus de courant
ont sont mes affaires c'est du délire
quoi certains du quelque chose repens
toi repens toi de tes péchés
[Musique]
il ya quelqu'un c'est vous qui avez fait
ça on n'a rien fait du tout on s'en va
qu'est ce que tu racontes regard d'or
ont dépensé ici
[Musique]
ça va
fais moi confiance
vous n'avez aucune raison d'avoir peur
qu'est ce qui m'est arrivé je suis mort
qui veut dire que tout ça n'est qu'un
rêve
non de souvenirs
tous ceux qui sont dans le coma viennent
au même endroit
lire ici en commun certaines personnes
développent des capacités uniques pour
découvrir leur qualité les gens ont
besoin d'un coup de pouce
essayons de voir ce qui est rend si
particulier
j'étais sur le balcon chef
et nous a appris à survivre ici
nous sommes là pour une raison tous les
gens présents n'avaient pas vraiment
réussi dans la réalité n'a pas encore
compris toutes les règles train c'est
moi qui ai tiré cesser
si seulement on défait de souvenirs
est ce qu'ils arrivent ici non attention
affirme qu'il ya une île dans coma où il
n'y a pas un seul chauffeur
on est toujours à la recherche de ceux
qui peuvent nous est derriére et
ma vie est ici maintenant
je me souviens que je pouvais pas être
avec celui que gmail
ici oui
ce monde n'a jamais été capable de
mettre en valeur les projets originaux
et insolites
pourquoi aurait-on besoin de la réalité
après ça il faut qu'on se réveille
pat réveiller tu comprends
ton corps est ici à comme à tuer
toi rien y changer la vie dans le coma
est tout aussi réel
et lance là
[Musique]
chef on a de la compagnie non mais oui
l'islam l'a dit me morice à nos
équipiers vous savez bien que je bosse
tout seul bien ou doctorat
pour tordre doc et je cherche mon âme
attention je veux vous retrouviez sa
traque et si vous en trouvez tous les
deux de ses camarades sous couverture
pour enquêter
je suis nouvelle infirmer ok ok reste à
l'air moi je te ferai un rempart de
montcornet ce fut plus grande victoire
non gym le bleu c'est avec l'eau qui est
maintenant le job
pas
[Musique]
très riche
c'est le plus beau jour de ma vie
la voilà je viens d'arriver au mali et
l'idée c'est d'aller dormir chez les
gens je sais pas existe à ses traits
premier épisode de la série j'irai
dormir chez et depuis j'ai parcouru une
soixantaine de pays alors bien sûr
ici c'est vraiment compliqué
et du coup je me suis souvent demandé ce
qui se passerait si un jour ça dérapait
vraiment antoine de maximy nos
présentateurs de j'irai dormir chez vous
a disparu alors qu'il était en tournage
dans les carpates présente agnès la
menteuse d'antoine lieutenant laurent
logis au logis et viendra porter à faire
d'antoine ya beaucoup de matériel et pas
mal de casse at il manque deux cassettes
j'ai peut-être antoine qui les a perdus
coup quand le premier jour tout le monde
que le fait d'être la versa c'est un
tournage qui démarre bien dans la joie
d'arriver à brens dans les contreforts
des carpates dit toujours le plus
important s'il m'arrive quelque chose
c'est vous finissez le film j'ai envie
d'aller vers le nord c'est pas su
retracer bien depuis qu'il est arrivé
dans le nord des carpates
il a du mal avec les gens toi rien mais
les villageois
mais si ce n'était pas un accident dans
la nièce et
j'ai l'impression que c'est quelque
chose de bizarre là non mais pour
avancer il faut des preuves le 7 août
dracula s'il vous plaît est-ce que je
peux dormir c'est au vendredi c'est
quand même très bizarre de faire ce
genre de geste discrètement là on dirait
qu'ils complotent voyant quitté d'abord
vous croyez qu'on pourrait retrouver qui
pourrait encore vivement
[Musique]